high school is a turbulent time for a
lot of us to say the least subjects are
a lot harder classes feel longer and
because you're older there can be so
much more pressure put on you by your
teachers and parents alike there's a lot
more onus for you to perform well in
tests and make sure that you get good
grades thanks to everyone around you
telling you that these are the most
important years of your life or that
your high school experience will
determine your whole future for good or
for bad actually come to think of it
pressure feels like a bit of an
understatement as if there weren't
already enough things to worry about
when you're trying to make your way
through high school the changes to
yourself get thrown into the mix as well
growing up and getting older often means
developing a further previously unseen
level of self-awareness and
understanding of who you are as a person
that can be true of any part of life but
high school can often be the first time
we're aware of ourselves in such a
heightened way usually everything we're
experiencing during that time can make
some of us self-conscious shying away
from others to avoid embarrassment or
becoming brash and loud to
overcompensate for just how uncertain
they might be feeling deep down then of
course on top of that already huge
mountain romantic feelings get thrown
into the mix as well sure in the grand
scheme of things high school romances
are usually just tiny almost
insignificant footnotes in the stories
of our lives but obviously they don't
feel like it at the time when you're
right there living through that part of
your life without the benefit of
hindsight that comes later your high
school crush can feel like the very
center of the entire universe being
introduced to and surrounded by more
people than ever more than any previous
stage of schooling means that romantic
feelings usually have a higher
likelihood of developing and are made
more prominent by the whole other
whirlwind of things that high school
brings with it case in point ellie was
having this exact problem for as long as
she could remember she had never really
got people they were confusing
complicated and completely unpredictable
usually they frustrated ellie which made
it hard for her to talk to most of her
classmates especially if she didn't
already know them that well the common
ground could sometimes make it a little
easier it helped break the ice but
finding those shared interests or
similarities was often harder than just
spending time on our own
then came along marcus or marky as ellie
heard he preferred to be called on the
first day of the semester she had been
placed in a new math class the second
markie came walking through the door she
immediately found herself unable to keep
her eyes off him especially because he
ended up taking the seat directly in
front of hers meaning he was always
filling up most of her view when she
looked straight ahead despite looking
like a skater type from what ellie
observed marky was pretty sharp she was
no slouch herself usually noting down
correct answers a few moments before
whoever the teacher called on whenever
marky was called on he also had the
exact right solution to whatever problem
or equation the rest of the class was
probably still struggling to keep up
with despite knowing very little about
him ellie couldn't help feeling a
certain new and unfamiliar way towards
this particular classmate it was like
they were both operating at the same
speed on identical wavelengths if only
she knew more about him and it was
during class that ellie had an idea
about how she could get to know him
better but without the awkward
uncomfortable interactions that came
from slipping about on the ice rather
than breaking it she could use
the doll sure she had been mulling it
over toying with the possibility for a
while but wasn't certain that it was
right for her to follow that course of
action but as the days turned into weeks
getting deeper and deeper into the
semester brought with it the possibility
that another girl would catch marky's
attention the way he had caught ellie's
just the thought of that alone made her
want to cry she couldn't bear to see it
become reality one day in class her
chance presented itself on what had been
an unusually hot day the scorching heat
outdoors was causing all the students to
groan in discomfort barely able to
acknowledge anything other than the high
temperature meanwhile all the teachers
could possibly do was open up the
windows to counteract the relentless
weather but it was nothing more than a
futile gesture sitting down in front of
ellie markey shrugged off the denim
jacket he always wore leaving it to hang
over the back of his chair her eyes
honed in on what she needed clinging to
the surface of the acid wash material
was a single strand of black hair she
knew she had to pick her moment
carefully if the teacher or any of the
other students in the class or worst of
all marky himself saw what she was doing
it would look beyond weird leaning
forward on her desk as subtly as she
could ellie slowly reached forward her
fingers wouldn't reach the back of
marky's chair was just an inch or two
further than her arms extended ellie
felt her heart stop for a split second
as her crush moved in his chair the
shift causing the jacket to move and the
strand of his hair dropped almost
falling out of sight sawing with relief
as silently as she could when she saw
the black streak managed to stay
attached to the denim ellie fished a pen
out from inside her pencil case leaning
forward again she delicately lifted the
pointed tip of her pen hooking the hair
onto it pulling it back towards her
before anyone saw she covered it with
her hand both to hide what she had done
and to stop the precious hair from being
caught by the warm humid breeze pouring
through the open windows
gently she placed the one missing
component she needed into a clean tissue
which she then folded four times and
kept in her jacket constantly checking
throughout the day to make sure it was
still there on more than one of those
quick spot checks ellie felt her heart
plummet downwards for a second when she
couldn't immediately feel the tissue in
her pocket only to calm down a second
later to realize it was still there with
its precious contents inside too the
rest of the day she felt tense drumming
her fingers together in impatience every
hour feeling like it would go on forever
it was just a case of waiting out the
day until that final bell rung the
moment she was able she rushed away from
the school walking home as quickly as
she possibly could one hand in her
pocket to keep the hair secure ellie was
lucky enough or unlucky depending on
your view to live in the same town as
her school and not too far away to need
the bus she could make her way there on
foot in pretty decent time normally the
buses from the school would pass her as
she walked looking up she saw one of the
huge yellow vehicles driving down the
street and a familiar face sat at a
window seat marky seeing him ellie
quickened her pay speed walking home the
moment she unlocked the front door and
closed it behind her she threw off her
backpack and raced upstairs to her
bedroom she knew exactly where she'd
left it as she flipped on her lamp it
was laying there on the desk ready for
her the naughty stalker the tiny doll
was made of one single knitted string
with a pair of shiny onyx beads against
the red of its face in the place of eyes
ellie had come across the little oddity
in a box of her grandmother's things
although she never knew her all that
well after she had died ellie's mom had
gone to clear her house up and came back
with a few boxes full of keepsakes these
are all your grandma's things i couldn't
sell or think of what to do with her
mother explained offering her the
cardboard box if you can pick out
anything that you like it's yours al i'm
sure grandma wouldn't mind looking
inside there wasn't much save for a few
old clothes knick-knacks souvenirs and
trinkets that were mostly all broken or
the odd piece of jewelry that looked too
worn out and rusted to wear but right at
the bottom was the doll it was wrapped
up in a crumpled piece of paper that
might have been clear white at some
point but i'd change shades with age
unfolding it ellie read the message
inscribed on one side congratulations on
your purchase of a genuine naughty
stalker do you love someone but they
won't give you the time of day do you
wish you could hear what they say about
you behind their back well wonder no
more using this fantabulous product you
can keep track of your loved ones every
move and their every word all you have
to do is get a single hair from the head
of the object of your desires slip it
under a loose string on our naughty
stalker and see what you're missing
another wonderful product brought to you
by the factory now that same crumpled
note was in ellie's hands her eyes
scanning over the instructions a final
time to make sure she knew exactly what
to do she didn't much care for the name
of it though naughty stalker the latter
word had a very negative connotation
what she was doing here wasn't stalking
ellie told herself she just wanted an
easier way to learn about marky surely
there wouldn't be anything wrong with
that pulling the tissue from her pocket
she carefully lay it flat on the desk
and unfolded it the hair was still there
secured between the thin folded paper
delicately holding it between her finger
and thumb ellie held the dark strand of
marky's hair in the light of her desk
lamp she treated it as gently as she
could making sure not to break the hair
worried that the doll might not work if
it snapped taking great care she slipped
it through one of the loops in the
naughty stalker's string for a moment
nothing happened the doll just lay there
on the wooden surface of the desk it was
completely still not showing even the
slightest hint of any change feeling the
worry building more and more her heart
drumming against her chest so loud that
she could practically hear it ellie
started frantically looking back over
the instructions in case she had somehow
missed a step she had no idea what was
meant to happen or even what she'd been
expecting but she was starting to think
that this doll might have just been an
oddity from an old toy store that
marketed them to children by promising
things that weren't actually possible
see you later guys a tiny little voice
came from the desk causing ellie's heart
to lurch in shock the doll was standing
upright on the wooden surface only
seconds before it had been lying flat on
its back as if by its own accord the
little knitted figure was upright like
it was a living thing and it wasn't just
standing its arm was waving and its
chest was even gently undulating to
mimic the motion of breathing the
naughty stalker kept waving a moment
only to drop its head forward and make
an exhaling motion that seemed to be a
sigh i really wish they wouldn't keep
calling me marky the same voice spoke up
again this time more clearly coming from
the doll ellie watched it closer
transfixed with utter fascination she
was aware of the concept of a voodoo
doll a mystical charm that contained a
person's hair affixed to a crude figure
in order to influence them through magic
this doll seemed much the same except it
was mimicking marcus's every move ellie
had overheard him talking to some of his
friends in the corridors at school once
talking about home
he lived in the next town over and the
bus must have only just arrived there
because now the doll was walking on the
spot the same heavy-limbed tired walk
home after a long strenuous day at
school she recognized the walk it was
the same one she did when she made her
own way back to her mom's house for the
rest of the night ellie didn't take her
eyes off the naughty stalker watching as
it streamed marcus's actions to her life
she watched in real time as he arrived
home sat and did his homework and went
back downstairs to eat dinner all the
while ellie was neglecting to do those
same things herself at one point in the
night the doll started dancing around
singing into something invisible in its
hand it made ellie smile uncontrollably
to watch she had figured out that marcus
was now playing some music through a
pair of headphones or a speaker and
singing along in a hairbrush dancing
like no one was watching the kind of
thing that almost everyone does when
they're alone but never admits to
turning to her computer keeping one eye
on the doll refusing to stop watching it
even in her peripheral vision ellie
typed the lyrics it was singing into a
search engine immediately paige's worth
of results came up for the song and the
band that had sung it they weren't a
group that she had heard of or listened
to before but it was friday she had all
weekend using her mom's card ellie
ordered herself a t-shirt with the
band's name on it premium delivery meant
it would be there before school next
week on monday she showed up at the
school wearing the new shirt it was a
few sizes too big but that meant that
the band's logo printed on the front was
bigger and harder to miss ellie had
spent almost her whole weekend watching
the doll as it mimicked marcus's
movements he hadn't done much but play
video games and go to the skatepark but
she made sure she knew what he was doing
anytime she wasn't watching she was
listening to the music he liked getting
familiar with it to prepare herself for
what was about to happen as if she had
been studying to get ready for a test
somehow striding through the corridors
full of students milling about first
thing in the morning ellie felt more
confident than ever hey marcus she
greeted spotting her crush rummaging
around in his locker and walking
straight up to him hey uh he paused
looking over her for what felt like the
first time
you're um
sorry we have class together right math
yeah she replied surprising herself at
how quickly she'd recovered from the
blow that he didn't even know her name
i'm ali i sit right behind you right
right
marcus smiled you don't have to use my
full name everyone just calls me marky
around here but you don't like that
nickname i can tell ellie shot him a
smile trying to do her best mysterious
voice how how can you tell he asked
don't tell anyone she leaned forward and
whispered but i'm kind of psychic they
both laugh and ellie caught marcus's eye
reading the band name on her shirt hey i
had no idea that you were a parallel
lunatics fan he remarked that's my
favorite band well i just started
listening to them ellie replied maybe
you could recommend me some more of
their albums suddenly the school bells
sounded interrupting their conversation
with a reminder that the day had to
start waving goodbye and heading to
class ellie was unable to stop herself
from smiling now that her way in had
worked for the rest of the week she kept
relying on the doll every moment she
wasn't in class she was holding it to
her ear listening to marcus's half of
every conversation the more she did the
more she learned about him what music he
liked where he was thinking of going to
college and what he wanted to study
there every time she passed him in the
hallway she'd give him a smile and wave
just to remind him that she was there it
was a long game but she hoped it would
end in the way she wanted nine days had
passed since she started using the doll
and that's when it started to become
somewhat unreliable over the weekend it
had been moving as though marcus was at
the skate park again but when ellie
approached him to ask how his weekend
was and if he'd enjoyed going skating he
looked at her with confusion marcus said
he'd been visiting his dad that weekend
and didn't have any time to go anywhere
near the skate park but that one
inaccuracy was nothing compared to what
she heard the doll say next still using
it to listen in on marcus's
conversations the naughty stalker had
started relaying words that made her
heart shatter into a thousand fragments
she overheard him talking to a friend
about her
saying horrible things like how he
thought she was weird and that she had
clearly listened to parallel lunatics
just to get his attention worst of all
was when ellie heard marcus say through
the doll that he would never want to
date a girl like her she was heartbroken
tears streaming down her face as she hid
in the toilet cubicle during lunch break
sniffling wiping her eyes in her baggy
band t-shirt ellie felt her sadness
turning into a wave of rising anger
throwing the door open she marched out
of the bathroom and started searching
the school for marcus how could you say
those things about me she yelled
furiously when she found him sitting on
the window ledge halfway up the
stairwell huh he mumbled lifting up his
headphones instantly noticing that she
seemed upset hey ellie are you okay
you're a jerk she screamed almost
choking on sobs that threatened to come
bursting out in a flood of tears why
were you saying horrible stuff about me
what are you talking about marcus asked
his face looking utterly confused don't
play dumb you said i thought i was weird
and that you never date someone like me
whoa ellie i don't know who told you
that but that's not true i mean i don't
know you all that well but i never say
anything like he tried to reply liar she
cut him off with another yell i heard
you i was listening to every word what
do you mean you were listening the
confusion on marcus's face quickly
turned to concern in his mind he was
quickly putting two and two together the
band shirt the question about the
skatepark have you been following me
instantly ellie felt her stomach flip
her anger partially dissipating and
replaced with fear no no it's not like
that she said trying to ease his look of
obvious alarm i i just wanted to know
more about you and now i do
what the hell does that mean marcus
asked sounding almost frightened i i
know everything about you ellie started
stepping closer thinking if she went in
for a hug that might calm them both down
i know all your favorite music what you
like to do for fun i wanted to know
because i really liked you but i didn't
know how to talk to you
stay away from me instinctively marcus's
arm reacting to her getting too close
pushed ellie backwards behind her was
nothing but a sharp drop and a flight of
concrete steps with a scream she tumbled
backward her body barreling down the
stairs until her head hit the ground at
the bottom of the last stair giving a
sickening crack as her neck broke
teachers could barely hold back the
students that came crowding out trying
to get a better look as the paramedics
came to take ellie away as they lifted
her body onto a stretcher nobody noticed
something fall out of her pocket an
unused naughty stalker doll a brand new
instance of
scp-693 now go and check out
scp-1562 the carnivorous slide and
scp-137 a real toy if you want to know
more about anomalies that might seem
like harmless fun and games at first but
can quickly become the stuff of
childhood nightmares if you aren't
careful